in a perfect world if everyone had  absolute information and everyone was  unbelievably well trained and you had a  great infrastructure and all that stuff  then yes the more products and services  you offer in theory you would make more  money but we don't live in that  theoretical world most of the time and  most small business owners are not that  good at operating and so in an effort to  combat that we have used this process  over and over again and it has worked  very well so  it is as follows we sell two things and  i've done this in virtually every  business that i've ever owned  two products or two services zero to one  million you sell one product one service  one avatar all right that's it one  channel one product one avatar but once  you're going from one  to you know one to three ish million and  you're trying to go to 10  you introduced the second product line